-Welcome back, my friend.
-This is so exciting.
-It's very exciting, right
-It's a long time.
It's hard to believe I hoste
one of these things for so long.
-You hosted one of these things.
We were talking backstage.
So, "Last call" --
I've been doing this show no
for six years.
-Congratulations, by the way
-Thank you very much, yeah
-Six years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's amazing.
-It's not easy.
-And you -- For the first
5 1/2 years of this show,
I would always end by saying
"Stay tuned for Carson Daly.
-And, by the way,
thank you for that.
-Oh, my God, of course.
-That was amazing.
-Sometimes, I would stay up late
just to watch you say my nam
and then go to bed
before my show.
-But you did "Last call" for -
I mean, talk about six years
you did it for 17 years.
-You can succeed
in this business
if you program entertainment
while America's asleep.
-Yeah.
-100%.
-It was always a show that
started at 1:37 in the morning
-1:37 in the morning.
-We were talking
backstage, though.
You know, I think people
might not even remember that -
Or was it just the first seaso
that you shot in 8H,
the "SNL" --
-The great Lorne Michaels
allowed us.
-Yeah.
-God bless him. It was great
At the time,
we didn't have a home,
so he allowed us to sort o
squat in famous 8H.
And we would shoot, you know
Monday, Tuesday, and Wednesday
and put up our thing
and get a bunch of rappers
in there and do our little show.
and get out before "SNL"
would rehearse.
-I believe I was a Season
guest on your show.
-I believe you were.
-Yeah.
-Thank you again for that,
by the way.
-Of course, man. That was big.
-I owe everything to you.
-That was huge for me.
That was huge for me.
-That was big for me.
Are you kidding me?
-And now you --
Obviously, not 17 years,
but you are in the 18th season
of the "The Voice,"
which is also incredible.
-Incredible. Yes, yes.
-And you and Blake are
the only ones
who have been there
from the beginning.
-Correct.
-But, yet, I think one of th
reasons the show continues
to refresh itself is the fac
you have different
people come in every year.
-I think when we started,
you know, "American Idol"
was obviously a trailblaze
for this format of shows.
People love to watch peopl
sing on television.
-Yeah.
-It's officially a fact.
But back in the day, I think i
there had been --
You know, if Simon Cowell
or one of the people on "Idol"
would have left the show,
at that time,
the press would've been,
"Oh, my God.
'Idol' is over."
When we came in, we were like,
"Hey, we have, you know,
these A-list artists
who have to tour,
and they're going to leave
And we're going to be like
you know, 'Iron Chef.'
There's going to be
a lot of them.
And they'll rotate in and out.
And I think it's been
a big reason
why the show has done so well,
because we've had a chance
to bring in, you know,
Alicia Keys and Usher,
and all these great people now
want to be in the chair.
-And it changes the DNA
of each season,
which I think is a nice wa
to keep it fresh.
-And we have Nick Jonas now.
-Which is very exciting, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's great.
-You are backstage with
the families while --
-While they're auditioning
-Yeah, while they're
auditioning.
I would imagine not only are
there highs and lows for them,
but by being next to it,
you must be on that
high and low with them.
-I am.
I get very excited for them.
I cheer when their loved one
gets a chair to turn,
but minutes later,
it's like being at a funeral
and it's very sad, because, yo
know, their loved one --
Their opportunity is
now stopped,
so, yeah, it's tough.
But I love it.
I love that part of the show
It's a lot of fun.
-I mean, in those moments when
it doesn't go the way --
And, of course, the show onl
survives because
there are winners and losers
so that's a vital part --
-They don't know that
part, though.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-Do you say like,
"I am so sorry for you.
We're going to get you out o
here, though, now."
-I've tried every way to mak
it semi-comfortable,
but, like, it's just impossible.
-And I assume you can feel their
pain as a family member,
like, the way they root, because
you have a beautiful family.
-I do.
-They're all here tonight.
-They're here, and I'm nervous
'cause I'm out here --
My entire family -- I've -
My family has happened
so fast for me that I've, like
probably been on your show
before I had a wife or kids.
And now I have a wife,
three kids,
and a fourth child on the way,
and they're all here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Hi, guys!
I'm just so old.
I'm like one of the oldest
employees at NBC now.
-And I, like,
have had a chance --
I was on
"The Arsenio Hall Show."
Did you know that?
-No.
-No, I'm not that old.
-Yeah.
But you were an intern for
Jimmy Kimmel's radio show.
-Crazy. Yes.
-So that does speak to how lon
you've been in the business.
-That's long. Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
-That you interned for Kimmel...
-In the '60s.
-...in the radio era.
-No. There was no TV.
-How did you end up
doing that job?
-It's a crazy story.
Our families vacationed in Mau
when I was like 8-years-old.
And he was on a -- He was
graduating from high school.
And we're Catholic, and he was
with his Catholic high school.
And we met and became friends.
And long story short,
when I dropped out of colleg
and moved out to Palm Spring
to try and play
professional golf,
I re-met with Jimmy
when I was 18
and he was about 24.
And, you know, I was his intern.
And he's like, "Here,
just come be my intern,
and I'll sign your papers
and you can, you know,
just get up early."
And I ended up falling
in love with radio.
And we ended up
working together,
and, you know, I sort of owe
everything I have to him.